[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
well happy anniversary
to l rushfoe
for being drug free
for an entire year
[ __ ] rush limbaugh
[ __ ] you
thank you
on this great thursday morning or
afternoon lunch time wherever you're at
in the country thank you for joining us
here on let's talk the tony michaels
podcast as you know as you know it's
trending uh today is the one year
anniversary of rush limbaugh
the dying should be so sad get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ]
the guy the guy
spread propaganda that killed people for
years about cigarettes and tobacco
companies
and lung cancer ended up killing him hmm
well karma's a [ __ ] i'm not
superstitious but karma's a [ __ ] so
[ __ ] rush limbaugh [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him
maybe we'll play a little video or two
um of how i feel
about rush limbaugh today i don't know
maybe we got a lot of stuff going on in
the news though a lot of stuff's going
on in the news uh we have a lot of
ukraine stuff happening um this morning
and the president united states talks to
reporters about what is happening with
the shelling of a school in the ukraine
uh of course uh anthony blinken uh we
actually have a secretary of state who
is interested
and in diplomacy to try to make sure
there's peace around the world and make
sure american troops don't have to lose
their lives
also lou dobbs is in the news probably
because he's a piece of [ __ ] that's
probably why i'm not sure why i didn't
go into that thread but we will we might
make it into that thread speaking of
pieces [ __ ] so is laura ingraham she's
trending as well um
the right wingers get the right wingers
got sloppy joe trending i don't know if
they're like hungry for sandwiches or
they're just pissed off that joe biden
[ __ ] crushed donald trump in the last
election i'm not sure which one it is
but um also there's a uh oakland hills
i'm not sure why this is trending i know
why it's trending i'm not sure where
it's at i just seen that um a video of
this uh country club burning down um
it's seen wow maybe we'll play that
video but i want to tell you today on
this on this show we have a very special
interview we have dakota adams you know
that we interviewed tasha adams the
dakota adams the estranged family
of oath keepers founder stewart rhodes
yesterday stewart rhodes had a hearing
um it looks like they're going to wait
till the judge is going to wait till
tomorrow to make the decision
to either
keep the detainment the pre-trial
detainment of stewart roads or to
release him of course him and his
attorney are trying to get released
back into the population and we get
dakota adams his estranged son feeling
on that hearing not just the hearing
itself but why they're making the
arguments why they're flimsy and what
danger him and his family may be in
if stewart rhodes
were to be released from pre-trial
detention if this judge makes that
decision
um in that way which um all evidence if
you looked at some of the
uh the actual quotes from the court and
the arguments that him and his attorney
stewart that is were making were flimsy
at best
they got the timeline all wrong on
ashley that they didn't end their [ __ ]
together and dakota explains at one
point what these attorneys are and who
they are and that might make it make
more sense um because in this day and
age make it make sense
is is a phrase that we have to tell
ourselves a [ __ ] lot a whole lot i'm
good morning to everyone um
robin's here
david is here good morning
uh bp
is in michigan
uh ann good morning ann
hello mj as always uh paddy's here happy
friday eve patty and then of course
yoda's here as well we have the whole
crew here today in the chat
and i'm sure more will be joining us as
we go along
as we tick along so here's what we're
going to do we're going to do the
shitless roundup today in the first hour
um and then at the top of the second
hour we will play because i had to
record the interview and you know
normally we have sometimes we have live
pop-ins but because of dakota schedule
we had to actually interview dakota
yesterday afternoon after the hearing um
so that way we could oh
pro fence supply says what about me well
you're here too you're here too
you're here too
good morning everyone good morning
where's uh mj said where's kaelin i
don't know i don't know she's usually
here she's usually here um maybe she'll
join us here soon
uh a bp says the oakland's country club
is in michigan so what we might get to
that video it was uh the crazy crazy
crazy crazy video a yoda called a pro
fence fency maybe that's the good
nickname for pro fan supplies fency
thanks for joining us thanks for being
with us thanks for chatting
do all the youtube things you know like
subscribe
comment whatever i'm supposed to say go
down in the comments below and
whatever i'm supposed to say i'm not a
good youtuber i'm just a [ __ ] talker so
but whatever i'm supposed to say pretend
i said that and then go do that thing
that you're supposed to on youtube also
also don't forget to go to
thetonymichaels.com the links in the bio
in my twitter
um it's also you can just go to
thetonymichaels.com
and go there and you can get you some
[ __ ] merch it's their [ __ ] hats
shirts um that'll help support the
podcast if you'd like also there's the
podcast upgrade fun we're still looking
for some software and this [ __ ] ain't
free
so you know go go help support us me and
gabe and the podcast there also go visit
gabe's um store i think i'm gonna put
gabe store on my website dude that way
it's there you guys can find gabe's
store too you guys love gabe here i
think gabe might join us at the uh after
the interview
with dakota he he helped record the
interview of course so um you will you
will get to hear um some questions at
gabe dakota and you get uh dakota's
insight on the on the hearing yesterday
for oath keepers founder and traitor
excuse me alleged trader uh uh stuart
rhodes and um so we'll we'll get we'll
get hot takes on that from dakota
um we're gonna do the [ __ ] list round up
here soon see if there's any more news i
i know you guys are watching the news um
with this ukraine thing the president
united states joe biden actually came
out this morning and said it looks like
russia is trying to instigate some sort
of fight um ukraine doesn't appear to be
fighting back
um you know taking the bait here
and that's i think that's important
to note that um
that it is it is it is
it is what it is at this point um i
think putin is testing democracy i don't
think this is a putin wanting ukraine or
anything that putin is testing democracy
because he knows democracy is his enemy
um he he knows
that
the more democracy happens the less
likely he is going to be a tyrant now if
everyone's familiar with history world
history we all know what happens to
tyrants when they start to do this stuff
when they start to test their bounds and
their
the limits of them being a tyrant we all
know what happens
you know they normally get drug out of
holes
and uh you know they don't last very
long so maybe just maybe that's what
putin's doing is he's in his desperation
for his survival he's trying to do what
all tyrants do which is tyrant and
and uh eventually it will be his
ultimate demise
um you guys know that malcolm nance is
on the ground in ukraine a lot of people
follow malcolm malcolm um he had some
good insights yesterday morning on
stephanie miller's show to give
stephanie a shout out i listen to
stephanie's show not every morning but a
lot she's on xm radio so you have to
have a subscription it is gated
um but i listen to stephanie a lot in
the mornings
and yesterday malcolm nance was on he is
actually in ukraine so maybe we'll go to
his account today to see what malcolm is
saying um and check that out during the
[ __ ] list roundup but speaking of that
why don't we go ahead and start just get
started again at the top of our state
stay after the shitless round because at
the top of the second hour we are going
to play um the interview and the
reaction of a strange son of stuart
rhodes dakota adams he's going to give
us his insight and what he knows
and what what he believes stewart's
actual motivations are to be released
from pre-trial detention um and also
some of the arguments that he gave how
flimsy he thinks they are and then what
kind of danger his family might be in
because of it
we also talk a little bit about the
bundy ranch if that's something you'd
like to
do so stay tuned to the second hour as
well let's get to the shitless roundup
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome back
to the [ __ ] list roundup where we round
up all the tweety tweets and the
training trends of the day as you know
as you know there's a lot a lot of news
going on a lot of stuff is trending on
twitter let's start with the uh at the
profile at the timeline here zoom out
let's see let's refresh here there's a
lot of stuff i retweeted
i want to i want to get to some of this
stuff um spread around the the link
today you're going to want to spread
this link around
at the top um so that everyone can go
watch dakota's reaction in the second
hour at the top of the second hour um
fun fact though fun fact of today
fun fact rush limb ball
has been drug free for a whole year
congrats rushbo
congrats buddy you've been you've been
drug free for a whole [ __ ] year want
a piece of [ __ ] oh look [ __ ] rush
limbaugh [ __ ] em uh well maybe we'll
play that later
i i really so
let's get back on this wrestling ball
thing
let's do this let's do this part really
quick all right not really quick we're
probably gonna take a few minutes on
this
a lot of people a lot of people know who
wrestling ball is that vile piece of
[ __ ] a lot of people don't know all the
stuff that he said and how he did his
radio show um i used to listen and and
and stay with me here i used to listen
to wrestling ball for years almost all
three hours and when i would work uh
years ago i would be in the car a lot of
times driving around and so i would
listen to wrestling ball now i would
vehemently disagree with 99. 100 of what
he said
and i would be screaming screaming at
the radio the entire time so that was
like my practice for this show for
[ __ ] years is to yell and scream at
the radio while rush limbaugh was
talking um he would do three hours of
vile [ __ ] propaganda every single day
right-wing propaganda every single
[ __ ] day now there's a lot of
significant things about rush limbaugh
okay and the reason why we're at where
we're at in the world today and in this
country specifically with trumpism
he is really the birth of this trumpism
stuff
you know to to un
un
undo
the the thin veiling of fascism in this
country for years uh conservatives quote
unquote would thin bail fascism with
things like debt deficits you know that
sort of [ __ ] and then it worked into
when barack obama became president it
became the tea party type [ __ ]
um obstruction and then it became
trumpism so there's been a lot of
[ __ ] bran rebranding over the years
of this right-wing fascism in this
country this american talibanism as we
know it today
uh where they're running amok these
[ __ ] they we even have politicians
making commercials talking about uh how
guns are are made we have gun rights to
kill other politicians in the government
and to overthrow the government like you
were running for the government you dumb
[ __ ]
people they really are [ __ ]
boneheaded they don't even know they're
domestic terrorists and they're domestic
terrorists like the guy down and
wherever the [ __ ] uh giving some kind of
commercial where he's shooting uh mark
kelly after mark kelly's wife
and
um was [ __ ] shot at a political event
in the face because of some deranged
person who would was believing [ __ ]
[ __ ] information on the internet he
was radicalized
by a bunch of dumb [ __ ] on the internet
to go shoot and try to kill a politician
this is all this is all in in this is
all part of the plan with wrestling ball
right to cause chaos that's the whole
point
to to to leak propaganda into the minds
of right-wing americans and to convince
right-wing americans and pull them
farther and further further right extrem
making them extremist
that's the whole point now ruslan ball
became less and less relevant over the
years here's why
in the in the late 80s in the early 90s
when rush limbaugh started his radio
show there wasn't a such thing as social
media right our new cycle was a hell of
a lot longer it was long
like like
maybe 48 hour news cycle right and then
um soon into the 90s we got to a 24-hour
news cycle right ruslan ball came on the
radio
all across the country on am stations
and then later in fm stations and one of
the biggest [ __ ] pushers of ruslan
ball was cumulus broadcasting they're
still one of the biggest pushers of
right-wing propaganda today
cumulus broadcasting go look it up i'm
not making this [ __ ] [ __ ] up
rustling ball would come on the radio at
noon eastern every day the reason why
rush limb ball was on at noon eastern
for three hours every single day in the
local am stations and that's the key
here
that was that was the secret sauce he
was a local voice he was a local voice
on the local radio station syndicated
right
it would pump his message into millions
of mines of americans
mostly those who are who are
pre-programmed to be right wing in the
first place
now the reason why ruslan ball was on at
noon eastern every single day
was to make sure that those people who
were gonna go home and watch the local
news and the national news at six
o'clock right you guys remember this
there used to not be [ __ ] facebook
there you should not be twitter you you
went home and you watched the news at
night the evening news now there was cnn
and stuff but not everyone had cable at
that point and not everyone was wrapped
in this 24-hour news cycle now we got
like a five-second news [ __ ] cycle
what rush limbaugh's
whole [ __ ] goal
with his radio show was was to make sure
that he programmed people
that when they watched the news that
night they knew how to feel about the
news
right because that's all it's about it's
not about facts it's not about real [ __ ]
it's it's not it's not about being
tethered to reality it's about how am i
supposed to feel
about the news you know that was the
whole mainstream media
you know acting like the media is a
left-wing operation get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] us on the left know
that the media isn't left wing for
[ __ ] sure
for [ __ ] sure we know the media isn't
[ __ ] left-wing the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] but rush limbaugh's whole
goal is to make sure that those folks
out there in this country that were
supposed to be right-wing that were
supposed to vote republican that were
part of the gqp
make sure that they were pre-programmed
when they watched the national news and
their local news headlines
when they got their paper in the evening
at the grocery store before they went
home before they listened to the
national news before they had a chance
the idea was to make sure that they
pre-programmed exactly how they were
supposed to feel about it exactly how
they were supposed to interpret it that
way in the morning when they went back
to the office went back to the school
went back to their community
went back to work they could stand there
and they could propagate his message and
his [ __ ] and the way you're supposed
the way you're supposed to feel where
you're supposed to feel about the news
because that's all this is these [ __ ]
snowflakes don't have any kind of
tethering to reality
because they're [ __ ] snowflakes truth
is their [ __ ] enemy democracy is
their [ __ ] enemy that's why we see
the gqp is supporting russia
because russia's whole goal here is to
question and doubt democracy that's what
putin wants
putin doesn't want a hot war putin
doesn't want to have to [ __ ] force
the american government nato to be to
apply sanctions to him
but he may have to because democracy is
his enemy
democracy is always a tyrant there's
always a fascist enemy is always a
totalitarian regime's
enemy that's it
that's what it is
you can say whatever you want about the
war in ukraine and the border and why
they're doing what they're doing putin
is testing democracy just like rush
limbaugh did for years and years on the
radio that [ __ ]
they don't want democracy they want
fascism fascism is not democracy it's
not it won't be it never be
and that's the thing we need to make
sure that all americans know
here i'm gonna talk a little bit more
about this today i had a conversation
with someone yesterday a former
republican
and they're they're they're sick and
tired of the gqp [ __ ] as well
so we'll talk about that later on in the
hour
but i think it's very significant
that we talk about rush limbaugh today
because th this this
misinformation disinformation this
right-wing propaganda didn't just start
with social media
l rush bow here
that's what they used to call him l rush
bow
[ __ ] that guy
mego dittos to him being dead
[ __ ] him
this country is way better off without
that son of a [ __ ] having a microphone
way better off
now because we have free speech in this
country sometimes sometimes it takes
someone
to kick the old bucket to get rid of
their voice
and i'm not i'm not much of a
superstitious person and i'm not much of
a religious person
but go grin reaper
[Laughter]
in this case [ __ ] him
we should all be happy in this country
that wrestling ball does not have a
microphone whatever way that that took
him dying from cancer that piece of [ __ ]
after he propagated for years that
cigarettes don't cause cancer [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him that [ __ ] lying bio racist
homophobic piece of [ __ ]
okay
maybe enough on rush
all right let's go back to the timeline
dude
um
let's see oh these these [ __ ] idiots
are getting sloppy joe
trending
this is funny number one number one
let's make this a little better number
one who the [ __ ] doesn't like an actual
sloppy joe if you don't like a loose
meat sandwich get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] you don't like a loose
meat sandwich even vegans and
vegetarians are like well loose meat
sandwich you know i'm a steak maybe but
a loose meat sandwich yeah that might
might be able might be able to get a
manwich
sloppy joe
crush trump you whiny little [ __ ]
i love that i love how i love how the
american president shows that he's that
he is for the american people in this
moment with putin trying to start a war
with america and its allies and nato and
ukraine right
trying to test democracy
here here's the thing here's the thing
joe biden said in his campaign
he said
i am not going to start a new war i will
not put american soldiers lives in
danger
and he's holding to that promise
he's holding to it he is not going to
activate
a military force to fight putin now over
the years and last in the several last
decades and under joe biden in our
current administration
the ukraine is getting heavy support not
just with diplomacy but also
also
strategic materials
to beat back russia if anything happens
now this morning we've seen that russia
is trying to instigate a fight
you have to remember you have to
remember that what we hear from ukraine
and the ukrainian border is different
from what they're going to hear in
russia
and the reason why is because the
russian regime
and the totalitarian dictator putin
controls that
that's why that's why donald trump
wanted to overthrow the government
that's why they don't want the free
press that's why they don't want people
like me speaking into a microphone
they don't like truth truth is not their
[ __ ] it's not their [ __ ] friend
it's their enemy
authoritarians hate truth truth sucks
totalitarianism
democracy tears down dictators that's
what it does now the good news here
is that whenever a a tyrant like putin a
dick a murderous
dictatorial
tyrant like putin
is doing what he's doing and trying to
stop heart start hot wars to try to tear
down
the idea that he would not be the leader
right because that's all this is an
attempt of doing
this is an attempt to convince russians
that he
he is the most powerful leader and they
want him to be the leader and democracy
sucks
because as long as he can keep this
democracy sucks stuff up
he may just remain the tyrant in russia
you don't think that the [ __ ] that's
going on at the canadian border
about these trucks clogging up the
economy and clogging up supply chains
is anti-backs it's not anti-vaxx 90 of
truckers in canada are [ __ ]
vaccinated
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
it is a [ __ ] right-wing
propaganda machine
funded by russia
and used russian propaganda to leak
through it is anti-democracy they want
people all around the world and they
want to prove not just the people in
russia putin i'm talking about putin
they want to prove not just the people
in russia but people all around the
world
that democracy just might not work
and putin rather he's right-wing or
left-wing it doesn't matter putin is for
putin
and trust me when i say this less
democracy means more putin
that's what it means
the less democracy we have around the
world the more putin we have and i'm
just not talking about him specifically
i'm talking about anyone who would act
like him as a tyrant
so sloppy joe
as they want to get him trending is the
president for a [ __ ] reason
and today he's showing he's going to
show
of how how presidential he can actually
be and what a commander-in-chief
actually [ __ ] looks like you whiny
little [ __ ] um speaking of a whiny
little [ __ ] you know even i have an
accountant i'm just saying even i have
an accountant
trump doesn't the trump organization
doesn't but i have an account i have one
okay let's hear it
i've lost my place sorry about that okay
lance cooper here says this is the worst
black history month ever it feels like
anti-black history month we need to keep
amplifying this everyone needs to um if
you find if you find uh lance post some
good stuff out there if you find um it's
a good black history month post post
them on your timeline you send them to
me in a dm as well um i think we need to
boost more and more black history this
month um i'd like to do that on the
twitter feed and i'd like to do it here
on the show
so if you have one send it to me we'll
talk about it because i don't think it's
getting in the trends
often enough we need to get this stuff
into the trends
oh look here what is this this is a don
speaking of the trump organization and
don jr let's let's do this
dude
what is this
did someone call gabe almost got it
you messed up my wordle streak what do
you want hey we're going to talk joe
rogan jr please stop talking it appears
to me very clearly to be the less
attempted cancellation of him rogan
canceled himself by saying a ton of
racist [ __ ] now he's not saying that bad
word like cursing it at someone oh god
of course you're more upset that he got
called out for saying the n-word than
him actually saying the n-word he's
literally
quoting someone else using the word
there's no excuse he said the n-word
multiple times over many years okay so
there's a difference nope there really
isn't there's a context there's no
context needed he kept saying the n word
there's context to what joe wrote about
you can easily explain it away but
junior i'm gonna stop you right there
wait are you defending joe rogan right
now because you want to say the n word
um yep that's what i thought so this
phone calls over you piece of [ __ ]
oh gabe never fails when donald trump
calls him um
hopefully maybe we'll hear from gabe at
the the end of the second hour here
after dakota's
interview
let's see i think we got um a new
tweeter um i said i wanted to talk about
um
speaking of democracy kailyn here was
pointing out to me that uh you don't say
early voting early voting in texas uh
mail and um voters in texas face game
designed to trick you so a lot of people
in texas are you know they pass new laws
to try to make sure that people can't
vote um it's backfiring in a lot of ways
um and this is what we need to stay
vigilant about we need to stay vigilant
about how to vote where to vote when a
vote how to you know and who to vote for
um this is going to be very important
because you may have to crawl over hot
coals depending on where you're at what
state you're in what districts you're in
to vote it is a possibility
she pointed out today that there was
even uh on the local news there was a a
very uh elderly gentleman in a veteran's
hat i think it was 90 something um he
was having trouble getting to an actual
drop box to drop off his damn ballot and
it was taking him hours to get the
ballot and he couldn't drive to go drop
i mean it's it's a it's a struggle for
even people who probably would vote for
republicans to vote that's how [ __ ]
bad it has gotten for these folks now
more importantly though more importantly
i actually talked to caitlin's mom
um kaelin's mom is a is a lifelong
republican a veteran
voted for trump twice
almost gleefully but after january 6
stuff started to change started to see
why you wouldn't vote for someone like
trump who is not only a [ __ ] tyrant
but a domestic terrorist and stokes
domestic terrorism
all in the name of gqp and [ __ ] using
using this guise of the republican party
and yesterday they went to go early vote
and her mom changed her political
affiliation not just because not just
because of trump but because uh and
caitlyn i think she was gonna post a uh
a thread on this um about how to
how to block fox news oan and newsmax
from your parents or your grandparents
cable tv
um
she apparently blocked these channels
from her mom's tv or mom and dad's tv
her mom has started to change her mind
because she doesn't watch
she doesn't watch
fox news anymore caitlin's saying no
that 95 year old man didn't even get
that chance
not about the dropbox he got his whole
mail and ballot application rejected
entirely so listen to that
it's not even about the dropbox to drive
three hours
this guy couldn't even get a goddamn
ballot
in texas
a white 95 year old veteran who probably
likely might or might not but who is
very likely to vote for the gqp in the
first place
their ideas suck
and they know that we know that their
ideas suck
so what they have to do is suppress the
vote that's what they have to do
we see a lot of these redistricting
redistricting gerrymandering happened in
these states and it's not going the way
that republicans wanted and really
honestly and if you look at some of the
laws that were the democrats were trying
to pass that democrats are trying to
pass would probably help republicans
gerrymander more the way they want to
cherrymander this is the same this is
the [ __ ] they do all the time
they overstretch their bounds they way
over calculate they think the people are
going to be on their side that there
won't be any backlash to their fascism
and there's going to be there's going to
be caitlyn says my mom voted republican
her whole life voted for trump both
times including just the last time
exactly
exactly and she's changing she she's
asking to change her party affiliation
all together
ashamed
i think there's going to be a lot of
that out there i think there's going to
be a lot of people pissed off
that the gqp the republicans are trying
to make it harder for them to vote
not just not just democratic voters
republican voters
why in the [ __ ] would anyone go vote for
someone who doesn't want them to vote
think about this an entire class of
people who is the most reliable voters
in the [ __ ] country repu older
republicans conservative white
republicans
who are either either long-life
republicans or or veterans
conservatives in general people who
listen to like rush limbaugh fox news
they're going to turn them away with
their suppression tactics because they
have to suppress the vote so much that
they start suppressing their own vote
that's how bad their ideas suck and
that's why we can have people like
caitlin's mom
who see truth as opposed to [ __ ]
propaganda
and and to make sure that they're not
programmed to the [ __ ] the
the actual fake news
and they get tethered to some reality
here
i mean jesus we still have people down
in texas dallas texas who think jfk
junior's gonna show back up
and run with trump and be the vice
president or pray i don't know what the
[ __ ] they think
how in the [ __ ] are you supposed to tell
with these people
how are you supposed to tell
so i appreciate kalyn sharing the story
with me and i appreciate her mom sharing
the story with me i really do
i it is it is it is very
very very very hopeful to hear
that people who voted for trump twice
saw what happened on january 6
especially if they served in the armed
forces that that was that was enough
that was enough for them
it was enough for them to seek out some
more truth that might might lead them
to vote differently
and lead them to vote for someone who's
pro-democracy
who's pro-democracy
this is very
very very important
and when i talked to caitlin's mom
i asked um how how many democrats have
you voted for in your life and she said
none she's never voted for a democrat in
her entire life
she's always voted for republicans
because that's the way she voted
straight ticket republican and i said
how many republicans are you going to
vote for this year and she said none
and i think that is very significant
i think it's very significant because we
paint this this dire picture in this
country with the gerrymandering which um
republicans did not get the
gerrymandering that they want they did
in some states like alabama and some
other areas but they did not gain the
seats that they wanted the game they did
not gain they did not gain
a major an easy majority in the house
which is really bad for them especially
for these american first marjorie taylor
green matt gatz joe kent types who want
to make donald trump the speaker some
dumb [ __ ] the steve bannon traitor tv
idea of a soft coup by taking over the
government
it's beginning to get harder and harder
and boy the griff's gonna get harder and
harder too
imagine imagine promising your
constituents that you would oh well we
couldn't commit the first coup so what
we'll do is we'll have a second coup
we'll make sure that republicans bang up
the districts that way democrats can't
win and we'll guarantee the house and
the senate
right
well you failed why do you think mike
lindell is [ __ ] broke and he's got to
have rudy giuliani sell his [ __ ] hippers
have you seen this [ __ ] rudy giuliani
[ __ ] debases himself by selling mike
lindell's sleepers
ah grandpa party maturity these people
really are in hot [ __ ] trouble here
listen
they're not getting what they want in
these gerrymandering districts
they're suppressing their own vote
because they have to have such high
suppression tactics to make sure people
don't vote in general
right they have they have and here's the
rub
they're even so hell-bent on making sure
the vote goes their way that they'll
pass laws to make sure
radicalized extremist secretaries of
state trump trump secretary's estate
which he's going around endorsing all
these secretaries which should give give
everyone the clue
including former republicans like
kalyn's mom to say nope nope [ __ ]
you're not taking our [ __ ] vote
you're not gonna do it you're not gonna
do it you're not gonna steal our [ __ ]
boat it's our vote it's our democracy
you son of a [ __ ] that is not a good
winning message for them
i actually believe there's going to be a
ton of backlash
and we just have to stay pissed and we
have to go [ __ ] vote we have to
engage
we have to engage in states like texas
where kaelin and her mom live and states
like texas is going to be super
important
to show
not just republicans but show all the
people out there who are pro-democracy
i'm not talking about people just who
identify as liberal or democrat i'm
talking about people who want a
democracy regardless of where you fall
on the ideology
the ideological
spectrum here
if you are pro-democracy we are going to
show
in texas
i believe
if we do what we want to do and have
strategic outrage and stay pissed and go
[ __ ] and vote and engage
that democrats can deliver that state
because republicans want to destroy it
at this point
they want to destroy it i mean they had
a whole year to try to fix the power
grid nothing nothing [ __ ] it you know
who cares
covet measures kill texans who cares who
gives a [ __ ] they want to destroy
everything they're trying to overturn
they're trying to overturn elections
through their legislator in the
secretary of state they want to destroy
your vote
i believe pro-democracy people are
waking up to that
and i believe i believe that it's going
to be very very very crucial and very
important to have these discussions so
when i say stay pissed and go [ __ ]
vote i don't just mean go mark a ballot
you have to mark a ballot
you have to mark a ballot
because that is the best weapon we have
to save democracy is the ballot
to pile these [ __ ] fascists
under mountains of votes
but you also have to engage you have to
talk to people your friends your family
members your people you go to church
with folks that go to school with your
kids
you have to talk to these people ask
them questions do you know where to vote
do you know how to vote have you heard
them it's getting harder and harder to
vote have conversations who do you think
is going to come up when you're like oh
yeah democrats making a heart no it's
not democrats making it harder to vote
have your facts in front of you for your
state and what your state legislators
are doing what what the republicans
didn't vote for in the congress
know your congress person that way when
you're standing there in your church
with your with your friend and they're
saying oh democrats they're trying to
steal elections like well you know the
only person you're our our actual
representative who's a republican in our
district voted against voting rights
they don't want us to vote
yeah do that
do that
oh yes oh by the way caitlyn um that
that's the other thing
um uh salman
uh
bo i i can't say i don't want to butcher
the last name um it sounds like he's
watching today um
he was at the
uh polling place and caitlyn talked to
him um he's a better fan he's the first
person of color to win i i believe it's
a city council spot he's running for the
district there
in texas and he's for women's right
extremist fights
women's activists healthcare education
and teachers um he's pro-democracy
that's the most important part um so i
want to say hi to him and i want to
welcome him on the show anytime
anytime he wants to come on the show and
do an interview
he's more than i'm more than happy to
have him
more than happy to have him so reach out
to me and i will i will get you on the
show i will get you on the show so stay
pissed go [ __ ] vote thank thank you
caitlyn for making me um have a
conversation with your mom i really do
appreciate um having the conversation
with her and hearing her side of things
um and hearing how she is
what what changed her mind from being a
inline trump's trump supporter by voting
republican um
just because that's the way it was and
and how
some of those things changed her mind
and also also um get that get that um
get that thread up on how to uh block
some of these right wing channels
and get that up and we'll we'll amplify
that i'd like for people to know how to
help their family members um get get rid
of this noise inside their brain so
thank you very much okay let's go back
to the trinity twins trendy trends and
the tweety tweets well we're just
getting to it
remember at the top of the hour here
we're gonna have the the response from
dakota adams the estranged son of stuart
rhodes
about
about the hearing that was yesterday to
try to suspend his pre-trial attention
uh let's see here did it do um um
and i i know i want to go through that i
i i was gonna talk about michelle here
um but you know it's just it's just she
yeah i'm not even gonna get there now we
we maybe we'll get to it after the
interview i do want to show this oakland
hills video
apparently this is in michigan
there's the video there
this is crazy stuff um images of current
fire at oakland hills country club are
chilling building date backs in 1922
awful now this is crazy fire
look at this
that thing is engulfed in flames what of
what
a crazy crazy fire
um no telling what caused this
but it looks like that thing is going to
be
burnt to the ground
to ashes
it looks like this is a historical
building sad to see historical buildings
go
but um you know uh in europe under
fascism there was a lot of historic
history that was lost
because they um
because they don't care about history
they don't care about truth okay let's
um so there's your oakland hills there's
the video there uh michael jordan's papa
john is trending uh jesus is it because
he's a
it's surely not because of the food
sloppy joe's still trending tornado
watch i do want to get to
do i wanted to see
why laura ingraham was trending earlier
lib dems lib dems is trending let's see
what lib dems is ooh let's see oh this
is this is uh uh foreign politics uh the
liberal democrats
[Music]
in the uk
i figured it was had to do here and here
in the united states um you know we're
going to cover united states politics
first i do want to go you know what
let's go to
um let's see if i can pull up malcolm's
i want to pull up malcolm's
um twitter feed here and the reason why
is because he is actually in ukraine um
that is going to be big news today
uh
let's see
malcolm there it is okay
let's pull up malcolm's profile here
okay what the hell
well i thought i was gonna blow up
malcolm
there we go okay here it is
um
but to do see if he's reporting anything
uh here's uh from five hours ago um he
isn't actually in ukraine so that's the
reason why um i actually again i i
listened to malcolm on stephanie
miller's radio show uh yesterday she's
on xm
um and i just i'm uh he's in ukraine so
i've been trying to follow ukraine
weather in kiev weather is bad uh but
very warm yesterday was clear so he's
talking about the russia it favors a
russian highway assault and air strikes
but optimal
for javelin and stinger missile ambushes
so he is he is kind of giving the report
of the weather because it may be crucial
in when and where the russian forces may
assault um so thanks for that malcolm
let's see if he says anything else here
i just want to make sure he's on the
ground there so
you guys probably like and follow
malcolm if you don't you probably you
should uh let's see
this is 36 minutes ago listen up at 1pm
i will be giving my military assessment
of russian forces
i will be also identifying evacuation
routes for civilians and journalists and
major cities
this seems pretty important
to do
listen this will be my last operational
assessment after a month of watching
russian forces capabilities and courses
of action in kiev ukraine unless i get
trapped in an invasion
with a doubt because i'm too
um
yeah so it looks like it looks like also
malcolm nance is going to
um
it looks like he's going to have a uh
a twitter spaces so he's going to be
talking so let's retweet this
now let's give him credit here too
so
malcolm is on the ground that not only
is malcolm nance media personality but
the guy knows
um foreign governments
he knows terrorism he knows russia uh
the guy has a few few ideas on tactics
now here's another tweet from him the
six combined arms army
uh
bypasses he's showing a map here
of how russia is surrounding the
ukrainian border now as you know this
morning
the uh here's here's aaron's video
malcolm retweeted it so we'll play it
here this is the president united states
this morning talking to reporters
um we have reason to believe that russia
is engaged in a false flag operation to
have to an excuse to go into ukraine
and that my sense will happen the next
several days so here's the president
united states let's make sure the
volume's up let's listen
right now
it's very high
because they have not
they have not moved any of their troops
out they've moved more troop in
number one number two we have reason to
believe that they are
engaged in a false flag operation to
have an excuse to go in
every indication we have is they're
prepared to go into a train attack
ukraine number one number two
i've been waiting for a response from
putin for my letter that my response to
him
it comes with that muscle embassy
they're factually here enough actions
are you standing here i have
still available yes there is because the
prisoner's not attached that's why i
asked senator senator
secretary blinken to go to the united
nations and make his statement today
he'll lay out what that path is i've
laid out a path to putin as well
there is the president of the united
states being commander-in-chief
um
as it were unlike the former guy he
would have came out and said a bunch of
[ __ ] lies and [ __ ] uh joe biden
actually being the commander-in-chief
here let's see if there's anything else
malcolm
says here about being on the ground
again
there's a very high risk here of some
sort of some sort of invasion in the
ukraine now again my belief is um
personally that i think putin is trying
to test democracy around the world um of
course this is about ukraine and some of
its borders but ultimately to putin um
for his survival his survival depends it
depends on
showing doubt with democracy because
democracy is his enemy in russia and
truth is definitely his enemy in russia
so let's not forget that we're 40 or 50
minutes into the first hour
we're 50 minutes into the first hour we
will um
[Music]
let's see what else did we have before
we get to the dakota interview it's
about 40 minutes long we talked to
dakota about 40 minutes yesterday um so
stick around for that here in the next
10 minutes we'll play
the response from dakota adams the
estranged son of stuart rhodes the
founder of the oath keepers who is
charged in a federal court with
seditious conspiracy yesterday stewart
let's just let's go to that um because i
think that's important
for that let's just talk about that for
a second before we get that up
so we can give some context of that
interview
[Music]
we always like to hear from dakota um so
this is scott mcfarland's
report from yesterday he says flash dc
judge says he'll rule friday on rather
to continue holding oath keepers founder
and accused seditious conspirators
stewart rhodes on pretrial detention
rhodes team says he wants a public trial
and isn't a flight risk so that's some
of the news from this from this hearing
um and you'll hear from dakota um stuart
rhodes seems hell-bent on going to trial
um it doesn't seem like stewart rhodes
is actually going to take a plea deal
now um that that isn't good indication
that he
he actually
he actually is in a position to not flip
um rather that means flip on you know
the other 10 oath keepers flip on people
who were above him and you have to
remember
on the day of january 6 and dakota says
it in the interview stewart rhodes
actually didn't enter the building right
um but stewart rhodes was giving orders
on that day because he was he is the
founder and the leader of the oath
keepers and while and was also the
leader of the oath keepers while they
were in washington on the ground on
january 6 2021 when they were trying to
when donald trump and his ilk
with which it appears to be help from
the oath keepers trying to overthrow the
constitution of the united states and
attempt a cheeto dust kangaroo coup
now
a little bit about pre-trial detention
uh and stuart rhodes pre-child attention
you know he's being held in an oklahoma
facility um
several weeks ago we've seen i believe
two weeks ago we've seen that the judge
did not grant him the right to stay in
texas
um stewart rhodes is hell-bent on
staying in texas and to get out of
pre-trial detention
which is uh is significant in that texas
is really close to a border somewhere
you know what i mean
oklahoma's not and washington's dc is
definitely not close to a border
somewhere
so that's that's that's the rub here
also also you have stuart rhodes
um you have stuart rhodes
really hell bent on
again not doing a plea deal now we i
asked um dakota in the interview
who his attorneys are and why his
attorneys are making some of these
arguments because you've seen publicly
some of the arguments that they were
trying to make number one that they were
trying to render aid to people which was
is kind of laughable because the people
the the stack as it were and the dakota
explains what a stack is to all of us
out here who don't understand some of
these militia tactics and some of these
military
tactical uh procedures
he explains what a stack is but the
stack that went inside the building that
they they didn't have any first aid and
first aid
they didn't have any first aid the aid
that was that the the oath keepers were
giving was across the potomac
where they were stashing the guns
waiting for an event to happen dakota
also explains that in the interview
with what what he believes
that the oath keepers would look for
when when
we talk about
when we talk about uh uh how the events
unfolded and how they would get to
martial law and the insurrection act
because that's the craziest part about
this whole thing it's like it's not an
insurrection it's not an insurrection
they wanted an insurrection these
[ __ ] people wanted an insurrection
and the reason why is because they
wanted the president united states
donald trump the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants himself at that
moment and you heard mike flynn parrot
it in the public over and over and over
again they wanted him to enact the
insurrection act so they could
so he could say martial law in
washington dc that way he could deputy
deputize a force of people
you know maybe an organized group of
people who i don't know claim to be
keepers of an oath the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
to take over the government
listen this is not this is not [ __ ]
hard to see
and i believe that th that stewart
road's going to trial because it's going
to be
when you have a trial like that in a
federal court it's going to be out in
the open
they conceal a plea deal for a long time
and some of the the information that's
given in a plea deal they can seal that
up federal prosecutors and the federal
courts can seal that up for a long time
so the public can't see it it is very
hard in a federal trial to seal anything
up that's set out
out in open court
that's going to be very important to the
process now
be very clear and understand that this
is going to take time
everyone out there wanting people's
heads on pikes today
is going to be very disappointed in how
the federal justice system works and how
federal courts work and federal charges
work and also how pre-trial detention
works
now it is likely that stuart rhodes
especially at their superseding
indictments which there is more likely
to be superseding indictments here which
all that means is that they'll redo the
indictment either to give more charges
to the people that are already
charged in this seditious conspiracy or
to charge more people in that
seditious conspiracy which is likely the
outcome
because as you will hear in the
interview with dakota here here in just
a few minutes
there was stuart rhodes was in charge of
giving orders to the oath keepers that
day in in washington on january 6.
but in the signal chats
they were waiting for orders for someone
else to give the orders of their group
well who else would they be waiting for
orders for
because there's evidence and dakota
speaks to it
that shows that they didn't want to wait
for orders possibly in those signal
chats
they were ready to move they were ready
to create chaos and that's kind of the
flimsy argument that they gave yesterday
in the court about ashley babbitt and
rendering aid
is they weren't really going to render
aid
to ashley babbitt or anyone else
that's just the excuse that they're that
stuart rhodes is using that why the he
ordered the oath keepers into the
[ __ ] building
and be clear dakota describes this too
about how they entered the building and
why that is significant and that and and
and that's why
the planning of this
is the way it is because stuart rhodes
has been at at odds with with the fbi
and the in federal law enforcement
before
over something like the bundy ranch
which um we do talk about in the
interview
with dakota here in a few minutes we
talk about the bundy ranch a little bit
but i do want to have dakota back on to
talk about that more in depth of the
of the bundy ranch because uh dakota
believes and i believe he's right that
the bundy ranch has a lot to do not with
just the psychology of why uh stuart
rhodes and the oath keepers did what
they did on january 6 but also
also legally like what their legal
liability was and it's kind of a
delusion but look in this day and age uh
these these these extreme radical
right-wing nut jobs
who are radicalized by this trumpism and
these lies this misinformation and
disinformation
they
certainly will act on things that are
completely [ __ ] delusional
if we haven't come to terms with that
holy [ __ ]
i mean absolutely turn themselves into
domestic terrorists knowingly or
unknowingly
just because of delusion i mean look
around in your family and your friends
anyone who's propagating right wing
messages either on facebook or social
media in general the people you know
they're becoming domestic terrorists and
they don't even know it
they don't even know it
so stay tuned here we're gonna go um
right after this break we'll be right
back
with the interview with dakota adams the
estranged son of stuart rhodes stay
right here we'll be right back
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the troop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today droop be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the break we have dakota
adams
um stuart rhodes
the founder of the oath keepers who is
charged with seditious conspiracy
um in a u.s federal court
dakota here is
stewart rhodes estranged son
thank thanks for joining us dakota
there's a lot of news dropping
we are recording this uh this afternoon
this is the afternoon of the the 16th
wednesday the 16th
um it's about uh
six o'clock
uh eastern standard time just to give
people kind of a stamp of where we're at
um there's a lot of news dropping today
there was a hearing today
um stewart's attorneys were trying to
get to where he is released from
pre-trial detention
um did you guys listen to this to any of
this hearing or are you just seeing some
of the threads what how are you guys
running back of the twitter live threads
um i was away at work and didn't and did
not dial in
um so people in my family dialed in and
listened in on the media line
okay so they so they were so they were
listening because it seemed like your
mom tasha was actually listening in on
the line
as it was happening okay
um so what is your understanding of
exactly what the the ruling is here i
know the judge is probably going to
delay their ruling but what is your
understanding of some of the
evidence not only that is uh stewart's
lawyer and steward is trying to make to
to get out of pre-trial detention but
what is some of the arguments for
keeping him in pre-trial attention i
know we talked about this before but
what's your understanding from what
you've heard so far
um
the crux of his argument is that he did
not make a run for mexico or try to
start an insurgency
that people know of
after january 6
and this demonstrates that he is not a
flight risk because he didn't he didn't
run but at the time it looked like he
wasn't going to get arrested or the
wheels were turning very slowly
so if it looks like he's going to be in
serious trouble then yes flight risk but
he still thinks he can beat the rap and
get a ton of attention for it
so you you do believe that stewart is
still a flight risk at this yes if it
starts starts to look like the trial is
going badly for him
that's when he will disappear and become
immediately very dangerous because the
for steward the next best option
after
beating the rap like several of the
people at bundy ranch and malhora did
the next best option is starting
a civil war
because that
person like on on a personal scale
the chances of being on the winning side
of the civil war or coming out of it
okay for him personally his odds are
better than if he just surrendered and
went to prison because then he's in
prison so this this is his thought
process right yes right i mean some of
this stuff is delusion right i mean you
believe some of this is delusion that
he's that he's making some of this stuff
up that you know well he's definitely
got the uh this the uh savior of america
complex right
but the uh yeah the whole crux of the
argument is basically that
you can rely on his klingon sense of
honor to not uh break himself
that uh
the fact that he's been a relatively
good boy in the sense that he has not um
orchestrated a second terrorist attack
since the first one right yes well you
know you know one one one is better than
none right and two is way worse i mean
how many can you add right
how many how many can you actually do in
your lifetime right you know like the
fact that you'd ever do more than one is
kind of crazy but right or one at all
then for that matter so
you brought up the bundy ranch which
which we talked about this last time we
had you on
you are under the assumption that the
reason why um stuart rhodes the founder
of the oath keepers who is diametrically
opposed to
um an insurrection or instituting an
insurrection act or using martial law to
take over the government as that would
be a coup
um which that was kind of their you know
their credo with or part of the credo
with oath keepers they did a 180 flip
and they've done this flip and you
you're you made assumptions that it had
to do with his
um maybe his activity at bundy ranch do
you do you think that that is still some
of that stuff that bunny ranch is still
playing a role in what how he's trying
to manage this whole situation oh it
absolutely is because he saw that uh
people who had criminal charges in bundy
ranch many of them
who refused to plea deal
managed to get acquitted and walk away
or get very light sentences when the
people who took plea deals early on uh
generally made out worse and then the
same thing happened at mount huber in
the end the male fewer the charters were
thrown out because there was so many
paid informants
inside the compound at the end of the
standoff
that made it look like really unclear as
to whether there was entrapment going on
or not
right and you've seen these and he's
learned from the example
so he's going to try to write it out but
if it looks like it's going badly for
him
that's when the switch is going to flip
right and that's and that's probably why
the federal judge is going to keep him
in detention i really hope so because
that's uh
it's worrying me a lot but back to you
just really quickly so let's say that
the judge says okay you know what you
you're not a flight risk
and will let you out of you know
pre-trial detention
uh
i guess in that scenario what happens
right like where does like does he have
to stay
like under surveillance like i guess
like how does that he would be
under supposedly under surveillance he
would be staying with custodians
to basically uh us basically sponsors
for him
is one way to think of it like okay
sponsor visa out of jail and but the
people he's staying with
from looking at the twitter threads i'm
pretty sure these are
um relatives of his who are rabidly pro
oath keepers
and completely ideologically in lockstep
with him so they wouldn't if he was
going to do any more terroristic [ __ ]
they wouldn't be monitoring him at all
they'd be placing him with sympathizers
seems kind of odd that they would kind
of put the trust in faith and trust into
a relative as opposed to a third party
who's well they were supposedly um a
political
relative
right right yeah very boring and not
involved with anything
um
but
it turns out that
their social media is nothing but health
keepership i see that's a red flag but
yeah
especially when he was the founder of
the oath keepers and they were doing it
doing this seditious conspiracy in in
the in the uh in the way of officially
with the oath keepers so that that
brings us to part of the argument that
um
i think i think that fell apart pretty
quickly was the timing of ashley babbitt
being shot that was a very strange thing
to bring up
because the timeline is only off by a
few minutes but it's off by an amount
that it can't possibly make any sense
right
yeah that was a very odd attack i mean
it would it would make sense if time
travel was involved because you'd have
to go back eight minutes or whatever to
to know that it was going to happen to
then take action in a preemptive or
premeditated way i'm
i can't wait for the conspiracy theories
to start popping popping up around this
people are saying that this is evidence
that the shooting of ashley about it was
a planned false flag again oh jesus
christ
i bet money on it well you know i i i
don't doubt you that that the crazy can
get crazier because uh there's clear
evidence just just on twitter you can
find it pretty pretty easily with time
stamps um there's a video and i think i
actually sent it to you to see what your
thoughts were there's a video
where the oath keepers appear in the
rotunda
and i'm not sure who they are it's hard
to make it out because it's not a very
it's a very fast video but they are
obviously wearing vests and uh uniforms
that say oh with the oath keepers patch
on it um and i'm not sure if one of them
is steward or not a lot of it's at the
backs of those people that are standing
there in the video no i don't believe
stewart ever went into
into the building
do you think do you think is there any
evidence that you've found so far in
your search that there was orders given
i mean is that i mean there has to be
something because there's something to
this um
the the the what is it called quick
reaction force qrf is that what it's
called there's something to that um
where stuart was stashing these weapons
apparently
they were going to take a boat across
the potomac if the bridges were sealed
off
by cops national guard
um they were
um ready and waiting and
they the kurf people were dinging
stewart's phone
over signal asking for confirmation that
was time to go in
while he was giving his situation report
from just outside the capitol
um talking about how uh mobs of patriots
had just reached the building and they
were banging banging on different doors
and was basically uh
live tweeting it out to his people while
his qrf team was repeatedly asking if it
was go time yet
right so what you're saying is is
there's several teams of people here
this is very strategic and tactical this
wasn't haphazard no this wasn't
happening at all this was pretty well
this is pretty well planned
they were i think really they were going
to try to get into a fight with any
counter protesters to create a smoke
screen
but they also talk a lot about
like implying they're going to force
trump's hand
like if he's not going to do this we
will and they're going to
like present the taking of the capital
to the white house at to trump
as they to come play if that's how you
if that's how you pronounce it but he
would never have
like if
the interaction act isn't going to get
involved because there's no antifa here
then we just got to do it ourselves
so they have to instigate
yes
going to instigate to give
trump
room
to invoke the insurrection act right
so it sounds like it sounds like um to
be honest by you saying it like that
that oath keepers um stewart maybe
specifically was way more desperate for
donald trump to remain president than
maybe even donald trump
he was absolutely desperate for donald
trump and president because he was
terrified of hillary clinton being
elected
specifically because it could mean
uh him getting charged for
uh his role in bundy ranch because those
are still crimes that they hadn't
prosecuted them for yet
but they could have and that's something
that happened after mao hewer is
people didn't go to prison
mostly over the mount he were standoff
the people that were in eamon bundy's
inner circle went to prison for bundy
ranch-related charges
that were filed and they were arrested
for under the cover of the malheur
incident right
so what what is it what is it about
bundy ranch that that has stuart worried
i mean is there a specific event or is
it just the way
the way that he's seen other people
treated um that were charged and stuff i
mean is there something specific
his involvement
for a talk with the fbi especially after
the sugar after the sugar pine mine
stand off as well
all keepers was involved with but he
took um
food medical communications
and multiple tactical teams with actual
combat veterans that were well organized
and not lunatics in the desert with guns
like many of the other militiamen that
showed up for bundy ranch the most
organized
group there
was oath keepers and their affiliates 33
percent
and they were the only ones that even
thought about the back end like
sanitation or running water
right like definitely keep it prolonged
right i mean yes you're not going to
prolong stuff with without having
sanitation or water i mean and that's
where i've seen people referencing that
they had also had 30 days of food
stashed nearby in virginia
so you're you're saying you're saying
separate from the bundy ranch the
insurrection that there possibly could
have been this some of the same type of
preparations made yeah because
everything everything they do
as far as operations go as a steward
sometimes has really weird and
inexplicable behaviors but he
understands
the importance of logistics
and supply
and demand right he's not going to just
haphazardly do something he's going he's
not one of these guys that's just going
i've got a bunch of guns that's the end
of my presence that's all i needed right
yes he one thing he does that i got to
give him credit for ron is
look at it as a full spectrum thing yeah
so as far as the the qrf and some of
these tactical teams because you know
some of this
from being kind of
uh stewart's teenage sidekick i think as
you said as you said in our last in our
last video
a lot of different events yes so
um so explain
explain to people what that means
because you know we are oath keepers and
there's 10 people charged you know you
know it people don't quite understand
exactly uh that mentality like you're
talking about and not only that the
organization and how
how they manage these events with the
quote unquote logistics like you said
either for weapons food supplies so so
explain
why it would be important to have these
different teams one that would go inside
the building one that would be with the
qrf
maybe some other team somewhere else i
mean what makes that such a tactical
advantage if
if they were trying to force trump's
hand or trump was trying to do the
insurrection act as some have assumed in
this case based on the documents that
are in court that they're charged with
the seditious conspiracy
well
the obvious thing is that the first team
that goes on to the capital grounds
would eventually breach the capital
they are unarmed with as far as guns go
but still carrying um like
i think like like hardens
hardened punching gloves and body armor
and so they are they are they have some
sort of weaponry just right firearms
they're armed in some way
yeah but they're uh
they're very deliberately not carrying
guns because then the capitol police
realize this
and they get caught with guns then the
lid comes off way too early right and
you can actually see some of where it
works out as a tactic
in the uh video of the mob being
confronted by eugene goodman
um you're talking about where he's
running up the stairs and trying to kind
of kind of coax the crowd into a certain
area yeah when they
initially confront him
he's got his hand on his pistol and the
this crowd of people with with their
flagpoles and their baseball bats is
advancing on him
holding their hands up going we're
unarmed don't shoot or the people in
front are and then right behind them are
the people with the flagpoles and the
baseball bats
and it's
it's the calculus that they're forcing
is
do you stop this mob
with a single well-placed shot or
and then give them
the martyrdom of you just shot an
unarmed patriot
yeah right in the middle of this protest
and also you're probably about to die if
you shoot someone if right i was gonna
say that the other side is like the in
the first thing that comes to mind is
like you know in zombie movies when
you're up against a crowd and you're
like i get a couple shots off i get some
but the mass of people is overwhelming
and you know now you've you know
potentially gotten yourself killed and
that weapon
is up in their arms so yeah they were
some of the officers on the outside
there were
almost protesters that shows how
pervasive the messaging is rioters who
were trying to
uh tackle them and take their pistols
right well so so to be fair with that
language because um we've talked to a
couple people that were actually on the
capitol grounds that day um that were
actually just filming for
satire right
and the
they they've seen it a couple different
ways there were protesters there there
were rioters there there were
insurrectionists there and there were
people with way more deep-seated uh um
conspiracy as it were to do this and and
the the reason why i say that is because
if you watch the ashley babbitt video
speaking of someone getting shot um and
an officer taking the shot if if they
needed to thinking you know doing the
calculus as you were saying
um when when ashley babbitt is shot in
that video um there is a tactical team
that is moving up the stairs which was
directly behind her
when they move up those stairs they're
wearing uniforms they're carrying
weapons obviously um
what what i find funny is
the oath keepers and other tactical
groups were moving the same way into the
capitol but not for the same reason that
those teams were um
can you
because it really is weird to watch some
of the video where the oath keepers are
almost look like official military maybe
even national guard at some point and
they're moving in certain ways trying to
work through the crowd they have their
hands on shoulders and doesn't keep
people from getting separated in the
press in the press of the crowd it makes
it easier to force your way through
you don't get you don't get your columns
split apart
but they they
were going in to do something very
specific once they saw that it was
already and this is the thing about it
that really sums up the uh logic of the
whole thing
is they're operating inside a chaotic
incident that creates noise and gives
them cover and they didn't reach the
capitol
until the doors were already busted down
and then they moved in
in their stack and made their way
through the crowd and i've seen some
people saying that they went directly to
nancy pelosi's office
right so so when you say stack you
that's what that's when they're moving
up the stairs
so they don't get lost right right and
then and then you're saying you're
saying when you move that way and you
actually enter a building that's already
open because maybe someone is was
incited and enraged to go open it for
you right like you know just
happenstance right yeah that is the
other that is the other thing is
that's all circles just a little bit all
the way back to the uh bail hearing
is
not since january 6th has there been a
large chaotic event where oath keepers
could try to pull something
under the smokescreen
of a massive riot or protest
right well and and uh you know they've
tried to have several sense like in
commemoration almost
of of your first note you showed up for
yes right right well and we have this um
this thing going on at the canadian
border which seems to be start starting
to head down the road of almost the same
kind of direction well i'll tell you
exactly what that is if but um if you
have uh you you had something you were
somewhere you were going uh talking
about the stack before we get off topic
yeah sure go ahead
well um i i think i think that that
all's i was trying to do with the stack
is that the tactical team that was doing
the stack ins inside the building they
had a purpose um you were saying earlier
that there is a team with the qrf
those guys had guns and live ammunition
they were across the river in virginia
where it's not illegal to carry military
power and weapons they were at the hotel
they were ready to go at a moment's
notice if they got word that they were
being called into dc but the noticeable
thing is the qrf guy isn't asking
whether trump has invoked the
insurrection act yet when he's messaging
stewart on signal
he's not
he's not saying that he's got his eyes
glued to the tv to see an announcement
from the white house that trump was
invoking insurrection act
what he's
who he's asking for permission
to get active and go in is stuart rhodes
so stuart would actually give the order
is what you're saying yeah he was asking
stuart
for the order
to go in repeatedly in these signal
chats and not mentioning that it was
conditional
on the say so of trump and the official
seal of approval i think that would have
been ideal
but i don't think it was necessary for
their plan there just wasn't enough
chaos for them to carry off whatever
they actually wanted to do
right it also makes a case for the fact
of like they're you know you could i
guess under uh
under a defense say well if you know
there was actually mention of trump then
maybe there's like misconception or
belief that he was the person but since
he was requesting permission from
specifically
stewart
yeah no one else or no other condition
for stewart to say the go-ahead
then it does put in place like okay
stewart was
in some ways you know the outside eyes
at the capitol that was kind of
the head of the operation right yeah
he was in a scene like a scene like an
emergency service was like a scene
commander's position he wouldn't go in
because that would put himself at risk
and if he's gone then obviously whoever
the number two or number three is would
then you know
take up rank but if he goes in and risks
his life then no one is there to give
the go-ahead from the outside and this
also keeps
the plausible deniability up a little
bit further which is how he got away
with things in the past just maintaining
a little bit of distance right because i
remember you mentioned that uh in the
interview with your mom about how
before
until this point you know stuart was
very very specific about when or where
they would do stuff like the proud boys
would go in and they were always on the
front line and they would get all the
media attention but the oath keepers
would not and the only reason that he
would have actually done something like
enter into the capitol or or send in
people into the capital was that there
was a sure thing he thought he had a
sure path
to
at the very least an outcome that
doesn't see him in prison
and going off of hit like the
photographs of him with michael flynn
that same day
i'd be willing to bet a lot that he was
in communication
with people who were in communication
with the white house and there's there
he was being
real probably relayed
updates
went through loop and
once they go into the capital and start
like searching offices
like
it's clear that there's not antifa there
so you just have to make as much chaos
as possible in yourself right to push
the envelope and see if you can create
enough chaos for
for them
for that for that switch the flip
because what you're saying is and and
this was going to lead me to my next
um lines of questions here is that
stuart was in charge of giving orders to
the qrf and the people that were
entering the capitol but there had to
have been someone
that was
relaying that message back to him of
when to give those orders right like
if the idea if the idea is that you are
going to wait for a certain event or a
certain position to where you have the
backing of a certain person
that would give you cover right that
would give you cover for whatever
seditious thing that you might be doing
whether you're doing it under the guise
of martial law and the insurrection act
you would have to have communications
coming from somewhere
i believe that that is what we're going
to see as the conspiracy
because if the government my view of it
is that if the government really
believed that it's just these oath
keepers
inside this planning they would have
just charged them with sedition
but because it's a conspiracy
it means it goes outside the bounds of
those
those people inside that
who were also unwrapped stewart up more
firmly because he was involved in the
planning and execution of it a lot but
he didn't do anything personally himself
right right so so what you're saying is
you are right i think they're going to
try to yank people that he was in
communication with
that were setting things up behind the
scenes
and you're talking about you're talking
about higher than what stewart was um
you know because we see the rolling
stones report from several months ago
that members of congress were were
bartering
pardons um for some of this
conspiracy work that that seems to be uh
and the longer we go on here the more we
see that this conspiracy how this
conspiracy was playing out and possibly
that the members of congress there were
members of congress that were bartering
with the administration and with other
groups
to trade chaos
for pardons um we even seen the
president the former president of the
united states the cheeto dust mobster
grandpa poopy pants himself donald j
trump stand on stage a couple weeks ago
and even promise again give a false you
know it's all [ __ ] because he
promised you know i'm sure he promised
he pardoned these people before that's
why he's saying it now i don't
understand why these people are still
protecting some of these [ __ ]
because i i mean frankly if he wanted to
pardon stewart rhodes he would have
pardoned him before january 20th
2021
uh well at that time it wasn't in the
cards because uh trump was mostly just
angry that these people failed him so
he's gonna leave him hanging out to dry
just like he's just just like he refused
to uh pay giuliani it's like failed me
why would i bother with you anymore yeah
right i mean that makes sense because
trump you know trump does take things
personally right like it's a personal
insult you didn't say this you didn't do
this you didn't whatever and i take it
as a personal event that like you're
attacking me
so it makes sense but yeah it's like you
know tony's
it's literally like two weeks but yeah
whatever plays to his face
well yeah yeah well definitely
the tail is wagging the dog at this
point for sure yes yes absolutely and i
think it's been that way for maybe
longer than we realize um you know but
that's i think that's one thing he can't
let go of is the vaccine thing because
he sees that as one of his personal
accomplishments
right he can't let go of taking credit
for the vaccines even though it doesn't
play well
because it conflicts with his own
personal sense of narcissism exactly
yeah well i was i've said it to tony
before i was like his his own ego and
narcissism will never let anyone else
take credit for something if there's one
thing he can leave office with to say
like this is my big milestone
accomplishment
that's the only thing he really has
and if he were to allow anyone else like
any one person any group entity to take
credit away from then it would totally
just destroy the image that he had you
know this legacy of the person who's you
know was able to save the pandemic or
whatever right um
so that brings me to uh some final
thoughts here is because um
obviously if stuart rhodes were to get
out on the streets people like me and
gabe are not and are not in such
immediate danger but speaking of trump
and his supporters and the tail wagging
the dog it is possible that people that
um that are close to stuart or have been
close to stuart or have spoke out or
have given the authorities um
information that would lead the the
authorities prosecutors and judges to
believe that hey he is a flight risk um
what kind of if
if the judge were to decide on friday
which it seems like that's not going to
be the case but if the judge were to
decide on friday to release stuart from
pre-trial detention what kind of danger
do you think that puts not only you and
your your mom but maybe somebody the
other people that were closest to her
close to you guys in it puts us and that
really there
everyone would be in extreme danger
on a shorter or longer time scale
depending on how things play out
so one of the first things that would
happen is he would start trying to
probably arrange having a visitation
with his children for the first time in
i think two years now well over two
years
and the just to look good for the court
which means he'd be around them right
physically
and the real danger is if he is
has access to the kids
when it looks like the trial is going
bad because i think the trial is not
going to go very well for him
and when it looks like the trial is
going against him is where he's going to
get unstable
and become an immediate danger to his
family
so it seems like you've experienced this
before when he's kind of painted into a
corner he gets yeah when he's pinned
into a corner he loses his goddamn mind
okay well and that and that's probably
part of the reason why
bundy ranch
um and all this leading up to like
you're saying why he felt like he might
have been painted in the corner if per
se joe biden would become the president
united states just like he was terrified
of hillary clinton
that create the the white house is no
longer hostile to a federal
investigation of right-wing groups like
oath right right which is kind of a
delusion because the white house i mean
to most degrees doesn't
they don't really control like everyday
fbi investigations right i mean i mean
obviously they're briefed on them and
they know about them but they're not
making these day-to-day decisions on who
to indict what evidence is being
collected this isn't like the president
united states is shifting through the
evidence of the bundy ranch in the oval
office i mean this is kind of god forbid
he has
you know the president you know if
you've got an administration that's
sympathetic to you or at least is
playing to a base pathetic to you they
could put pressure on the fbi and the
department of justice
right right
and and that's his game plan right
that's his game plan is to get the best
situation that he possibly can for the
fears that he would suffer consequences
um just the same way he's doing today in
this in this hearing so what is your
opinion to close out here what is your
opinion on on the what you know about
what was said today at the hearing what
you know about this judge because it
seems like you've done a little bit of
research on on this judge of what
decisions they made so what is your
opinion what do you think decision that
this judge is going to make on friday or
maybe you hope that he's going to make
it i think
he is going to be held pending his trial
i think his spell is going and his
appeal for bell is going to be denied
and it's because
they completely failed to address the
escape tunnels thing that was cited in
the original ruling
um they
failed to explain why this
this custodial family would be able to
properly monitor him despite being
ideologically wild to his cause
right
um
and their arguments around the specifics
of why stewart is not flight risk
are
kind of weak right i think yeah
they really didn't prove that
like they didn't really make a strong
case for why the initial decision would
have been flawed right
well i i i think you're correct there
that that even even in the lead up to
this hearing their arguments um in the
actual briefing um was flimsy at best um
with the ashley babbitt timeline thing
going on
basically in a lie right there yeah and
the custodial the custodial family thing
that's also an implicit lie because
right i believe the way it went down was
the husband testified so
my father's cousin huge uh
huge oath keepers fan i got you well so
that that actually one one more thing
because that brings up some another
question in my mind of speaking of oath
keepers and fans and going on uh this
kelly's so real character that has
placed herself in the story um she was
running for a seat for the state
legislature apparently that's what she
was saying publicly she is no longer
running for that seat i guess
um she like self-proclaimed her self the
leader of the oath keepers she was
posting a lot of um
not just uh pro oath keepers but a lot
of
to be frank racist [ __ ] on her on her
twitter feed um you know really not not
giving any good reason why she would
want to be the leader of any group that
was uh had anything to do with a con
seditious conspiracy but i guess my
question is she has now said she's not
the leader she's she was she is
she stepped down after stuart's denied
bill the first time
uh said that it didn't think it was
going to be a long haul she's uh was
denying having had a personal
relationship with him now way earlier i
meant to bring it up is
early on
from basically from right after the
beginning when it first started to kind
of slide into being a militia lots of
people inside of keepers would have been
um
completely open to insurrection and
insurgency if they felt like it was
necessary or justified
just that the ten standing orders are
diametrically opposed to
that way of thinking after a military
coup and martial law which is what
michael flynn was advocating for while
he was meeting with trump behind closed
doors okay that right there should have
been the part that put the kobash on not
necessarily
carrying out insurrection in itself
but
the legal mechanism behind it and the
people involved
that would have been unpalatable to all
those keepers
what was your question gabe oh no well
earlier you mentioned that we actually
mentioned the truckers and you said you
had a take on that so i'd be curious to
know what that is you know
too far off topic but i figured it would
be worth it
my take um is that
this is
the next round of
the
first draft
rally in dc from like the old screen
caps that were circulating for their
original on parlor
for their original plan which was just a
wall of bodies to shut off washington dc
shut it down only permit
um
the correct republican lawmakers through
and not to allow anyone from the
democratic party or anything called
rhinos in or out of dc at all
and any um action by the police to move
them or break up the protests would be
the instant start of a hot civil war
you know that brings up i i can't
remember who was in the video in the
last week or so but they were saying
they need to shut down capitals and
and
in california capitals in new york the
washington d.c i feel like they've been
saying that for for a while right they
always whenever they're talking about
shutting down to like show you know
who's who's in power because i feel like
i've heard that before it was like the
state capitals is what they want to shut
down in order to force the hand well
yeah they did it would they did didn't
they do this um um you know after
after the january 6th well they did it
before they tried a couple different
little rounds
you know during the stop the steel kind
of campaign and then then of course the
insurrection happened and then they
tried it a couple different times of
their capitals um because there was
different events like the my pillow guy
was
was propagating you know there was the
march 4th thing and then the september
89th and i am [ __ ] it's hard to tell
with with mike lindell at this point
like where he moves the goalpost but as
he was moving the goalpost you know they
would have try to have different events
and this sort of thing and i think i
think maybe you're right that they're
you know this is kind of pre-planning
and they're using canada and a foreign
country type thing um to try to
determine the testing right now right
exactly
they're figuring out um what services
they can use that will
transfer donations without blocking them
that's what now gives send go is going
to be
the mainstay nobody's going to bother
with gofundme or anything anymore
they're try work they've worked on how
to keep people off of their zello
channels so they
don't well
they haven't figured out they haven't
figured out twitter we were talking
about this today you're talking about
the ram ranchers resistance which is
absolutely
[ __ ] incredible and honestly maybe
the ram ranchers are the
you know the anti-oath keepers at this
point you know i don't know i'm just the
real real patriots in this situation
right exactly well you know
it actually was a good resistance and it
was one of the best um non-violent
protests that we've seen in a long time
have you have you seen the some of the
videos that were made by the militiamen
inside the malheur wildlife refuge and
people would send them dildos and like
55 gallon drums yes that one i do
remember the amazon order that came here
yeah they would make because they're
asking for
their standoff and they would make
videos posing with all the [ __ ] people
sent them talking about how awful it was
people were doing this
that would very much remind me of that
and i just love that um ram ranch is
culturally relevant again i feel like
its heyday was way too short
right we got right there were like uh i
think i posted on twitter somewhere
there was like a
there are like a bunch of like fandom
specific parody versions there's a
warhammer 40 000 version of the rainbow
of song which is about as homoerotic as
you can possibly get
i'm glad that it's back right well not
not to plug it too much but i actually
put a ram a ram ranch resistance 2022
um t-shirt so if anyone
on the merch store so if anyone wants to
go grab a ram
ranch resistant i think it's hilarious
we watched the video today where it's
inside one of these yellow
kind of radio rooms or whatever the hell
it is and um they start playing the song
the the the song and they're talking
about you know these guys giving
fellatio to each other and stuff and
that of course
it is your it is your program huh what's
that if you if you want you can say
sucking [ __ ] if you want yeah
i mean sucking [ __ ] fellatio you know
i'm trying to i'm trying to keep it
clean for the children to go to jesus
christ
they're gonna take out of the children
and family well you know we're not in
the children and family category for
sure now i do we do have several several
videos that are that are marked adult
only but you know i i'm not sure there's
no nudity in them i'm just not sure
but but we did play we did play the song
today or part of it right so we played
the sucking cox part on the show today
so no this you can you can say sucking
cox on tony michael's podcast that is
that is absolutely especially when
you're referring to the ram ranchers
resistance um i feel like i should i
feel like in addition
i feel like though i wanna i feel like
ram ranchers it's like the resistance
tour
and then you just gotta have to put a
bunch of city oh yeah yeah sure sure and
where are they together and you know
what it might be a short tour like it
could be like ottawa
and then just like
ottawa right and then maybe no short
tour no pun intended no plan
on the short tour thing everything else
has been canceled that's why well dakota
i really appreciate you coming and
joining us again and we really want to
have you back as this as this news
develops so if there's new news next
week or the week after uh please please
come back and we'll talk to you more
because i really uh the other thing i'd
like to do
and i know the audience wants to know
more about the bundy ranch and some of
that stuff you know some of the
specifics that happened that with the
oak keepers
and kind of do a deep dive into that so
we'd really like to have you here with
that kind of stuff too
is there anywhere where the
are there is there anywhere that you
know of where people saved all those
keepers videos
because they had a youtube video where
they had a round table discussion
going out over there after action the
oath keepers after action report from
their involvement in bundy ranch
i'd know but we can probably try to dig
something up for you if you'd like i
tried
for you an extensive video that went
into a lot of stuff that is not widely
known and it shows like the
dysfunctional internal politics of the
militia movement and like showcases it
in a really interesting way cool yeah
well maybe
we'll chat about that um offline and
we'll we'll uh we'll try to see if we
can dig that up and then maybe maybe
we'll have you back in the next couple
weeks and we'll talk about that
specifically because i know the audience
um is interested in that type of content
of breaking down exactly what all this
stuff means because it is kind of
confusing like even the qrf and some of
the language the stack a lot of people
aren't part of that
militia culture so they don't they don't
understand what that stuff means right
they just they just don't that's why
even some of those videos uh seeing the
oath keepers at the capitol in those
uniforms makes it confusing where they
almost look like they're the actual
military and that is that is the intent
that's right
exactly exactly so thanks dakota for
joining us
especially in the green with the patches
they look at first class like they could
be state like state police oh yeah
absolutely
if you don't know where we're at naked
eye nobody knows so you'd be right all
right trust this person especially the
way they they have helmets on and some
of the gear um it looks you know super
quote-unquote official um you know but
rather that
intention or not it seems intentional to
me um you're saying it's intentional
knowing knowing the militias thanks for
joining us thanks for giving us your
insight on the hearing today um and if
we have more news we'll bring you back
thanks dakota appreciate it everyone
stick around we'll be right back after
this message
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
brandon
[Music]
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em [ __ ] welcome
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to
the tony michaels podcast
we have dave rocking out here
rocking his ass off
what a great interview
that was yeah man i always i always like
having uh dakota on giving us his
insight into um
the the oath keepers and stewart roads
as the stewart rhodes uh news develops
i i think there's a few significant
things that he says in this interview
number one is the the fact
i think a lot of people are missing like
the seditious conspiracy that it goes
beyond stuart rhodes right like right he
was waiting like the signal chats they
were like we shouldn't wait for orders
right yeah like so like if they didn't
get the order then they should they
should create right in a situation where
they don't need one they make a problem
to then fix it kind of thing right
because they
well
we lost gate there for a second but they
knew they knew specifically what was
going to happen um when when they were
talking about the i think we got them
back now there we go yeah yeah they are
so excited i'm sorry you just you know
but no no you make a good point that
that like they were trying to create
this chaos that way if they didn't have
the event that they were really looking
for they can manufacture an event that
they knew that maybe someone give an
order because they were told that
someone would give an order but more
importantly it's possible that they
thought that hey we may be able to force
someone to look like they gave an order
right like it's all this this illusion
type thing and that's that's where some
of this stuff came from i i think it's
um
i really liked him back on and really oh
yeah dive into the militia
the militiamen and the militia group
i mean there's a ton more that he could
i mean this was only based on this one
recent update so like
there's so much more of the bundy rants
people don't know about and even said
you said like there's a lot of
terminology and verbiage that people
don't know
um that
you know that haven't been involved with
like militia groups so it would be uh a
bit of a ted talk you know that that's
that's uh i like that point because
uh you know a lot of folks and i i've
been saying this that i had a friend of
mine who's it's not a dumb person
it's not you know a
a d couple from the news didn't even
know the story about the trump white
house destroying documents had no clue
about the story which i think is one of
the biggest stories that there is
another really big story that should be
like national headlines for days and
days and days is that the accounting
firm for the former president in his
business like said hey we're not even
willing to stand behind these records
that we can yeah yeah this is 10 years
these records uh
yeah and and we we did them and we know
they're fraud yeah
because because again in a case like
that you're you know it's like you
either are on the side of the defense or
side of the prosecution and they chose
the prosecution
but even even all the way you know
because that has to do with this
business but you get to this january 6th
thing right and who's going to flip
who's going to turn you know we see rudy
giuliani go to the january 6th select
committee we've seen stuart rhodes go to
the january 6th select committee you
know how far does this conspiracy go for
sedition now we've seen the reports of
the rolling stones of the members of
congress who were trying to barter
pardons uh you know that was the
reporting
trying to barter pardons from the
administration to some of these actors
that would uh do the acting
and that goes back to knowing that
terminology right because
you you see the videos and the pictures
of the oath keepers at the capitol and
then you see pictures of like law
enforcement and even the national guard
it's hard
it's hard anyone who doesn't know like
dakota knows oh that's that and that's
that and that's that it's hard to really
determine well are those oath keepers
are those nasty guardsmen like sometimes
it's hard to tell and if you can't even
figure out a story as easy as hey they
were destroying [ __ ] top secret
documents inside the white house and hey
the the former guys [ __ ] accounting
firm has is joining the prosecution in
the civil and the criminal case in new
york against the trump organization like
if you can't even break those stories
through how are you gonna break through
the story that they tried to overthrow
your government yeah this isn't joe
biden's government this isn't nancy
pelosi's this is our government it was
our vote that they were trying to
overturn with the cheetos kangaroo like
how do you break that through so
um some of that language that is being
used and and i think sometimes the story
gets suppressed because of like the
stack and the qrf and all these things
that people you just don't know right
look they were strategic and going into
the capitol and like dakota said they
waited for people to break down the door
so they could just walk right through
them right like this is all part of the
strategic plan is to not be culpable for
breaking and entering right
uh you know but that's part of the
seditious conspiracy i think so um i i
really i really do like having dakota on
i think he gives a lot of good insight
oh yeah
um what what do you think about his
insight into the ram ranchers and this
uh ram ranchers
uh i
and and sucking [ __ ] you know he made
sure to
really make sure that we said sucking
[ __ ] as if we're opposed if we're
opposed to that he was like don't be
don't be shy you could say and you're
like all right yeah whatever i i'm not
to say you know fellatio sucking [ __ ]
whatever you want to say you know yeah
yeah no jobs i'm into it uh i mean i
think he's pretty spot on you know
that's
the word that was used as market
research right like they're testing now
in canada
to see what they can get away with in
the us but i think the most important
thing that i don't think really touched
on was like
um
is we're watching
right wing media
play
as the sympathizers for
this group right because they're like oh
look at these people or stand up for
their rights and you know they don't
want to put that thing in their body and
this and that right and so saying like
oh it's the the freedom and the right to
to do what you want with yourself right
right and
that's that's that's that's the guys
that they're using right exactly that
yeah that's marketing yeah right exactly
it's really it's really democracy sucks
uh is the is the real message here but
what's really funny is how much
that because right now they're like oh
well you stand up against the government
and you're standing up against the rich
and you're holding you're holding them
accountable in the sense of like
uh the working class actually has all
the power which is true
however
you don't see a lot of the working class
um
kind of join in arms to go against
corporations or the working or the the
upper class or government or whatever so
i find it really interesting that the
right-wing media right now is actually
pro
like they're pushing this and it's like
oh great so you guys are for this right
so you're for supporting the working
class stand up against corporations who
are taking
advantage of them or what have you
right um
it's just also it's it's just funny
because like right now they'll be in
support but then later on they'll be
like oh corporations uh tax incentives
uh like you know all right you know you
know right right well they should stick
that somewhere um
back to the the corporatism the
capitalism right the fascism thing is
that i believe that uh republicans the
gqp has been um this gqp this fascist um
um party has been amongst us they
haven't really had the reigns of the
republican party because the republican
party has understood for a long time
that like the outright fascism thing
doesn't work very well in with
capitalism like fascism and capitalism
don't mix together and the reason why is
because fascists like to tell
capitalists what to do and that is not
capitalism like capitalism likes to tell
that the market what to do right like
right right
well it works the market right you know
you've got whatever uh right but but but
that's that's the part about a fascist
state that a lot of people don't
understand is like
fascist state your your little free
market capitalism your little freedoms
and your
your your ability to choose anything you
are a [ __ ] idiot if you think under a
corporate fascist state that you're
going to choose
anything like they're going to choose it
for you you don't get a choice there's
no free market in corporate fascism like
they they will own the corporations they
will own the people on the corporations
and if they don't own them they'll kill
them like
like why do you think the gun culture in
this country has escalated to a point
where a gun fixes everything like that's
the fascist motto it's no longer it's no
longer hunting it's guns are designed to
kill people and they're designed for
for
legitimate political discourse right
like that's the that's the aim and
that's the direction and this this
this anti-vaxx um anti-choice
thing that they're doing and trying to
market against democracy because i
believe this is what putin is doing not
on the ukraine border and on the
canadian border because i think i don't
i am not putting it past a russian
propagandist to use the right wing in
our country and elsewhere around the
world to pro
propagate their anti-democracy message
because putin knows that his main enemy
is democracy that is his enemy in russia
not just around the world but in russia
specifically if people in russia find
out that this democracy stuff works oh
[ __ ] he's in big trouble right right
right and and at tyrants
i don't know if anyone knows but tyrants
in history that do what putin's doing
right now
it normally
normally does not end well for that
tyrant i mean um i don't know if we we i
don't know if we have to go back in the
history books too far and pick out too
many of them it's kind of crazy that uh
it's like hey guys um
you know
70 80 years ago
right you know uh we we we fought this
war it was a world one it was crazy
um against this very thing
and now if people are like
is it so bad right like
especially the right-wing media they're
like right putin bad are putin good
biden bad we want biden to lose because
we need to win election like really
honestly if the republican party would
just stand behind america on this right
they would actually probably get more
respect and more votes and they could
take credit for part of it right like
like
you know in the political body
republicans could honestly have this
situation where they're quote unquote
pressuring biden to do more to be
anti-russia and anti-putin like we
pushed him that way he would have been
he would have been weaker on putin if we
would i mean you know this is all
politics this is all noise they could do
that but they're not they're actually
they're actually holding up and
propagating putin's message to own the
libs to own biden to make him look weak
damning this morning this you know
russia's russia's doing this false flag
and all of a sudden
all of a sudden sloppy joe starts to
trend right like just all of a sudden
like out of nowhere this morning sloppy
joe starts to trend because because
putin is firing or that putin's army is
firing shells into a school to try to
instigate ukraine
into firing back so he can tell the
russian people see see they're firing on
us we have to go to war because i think
that's the thing here is putin knows
that russia doesn't want the russian
people do not want to go to war right i
think i think he knows that yeah that's
a stick
what what else do we have um for for
this week because i know we've got the
bonehead of the week poll
um we've got some boneheads on there
explain to people why we're on the air
because there was a little confusion
about one of the boneheads and uh we we
didn't quite explain exactly who this
person was but explain
explain i don't think he's gonna win
because of that but yeah yeah okay so
we've got three i think this is
significant news right so we've got eric
trump obviously he seems to be uh
uh mr gummies um
and then we've also got uh who's jim
jordan was the other yes
and the third one is dennis oswalt now
for people who don't know who dennis
oswald is i believe that's how he says
it um
he is part he's the chair the head chair
of the
uh international olympic committee that
is just that is the one that is deciding
um
you know uh basically
what's going on with the russian skater
the 15 year old who accidentally took
her grandfather's heart medicine and if
anyone doesn't know what this heart
medicine does it lowers your uh your
heart rate so you're able to exer
basically exert yourself a little bit
more um so you can uh you could
basically push your body further and
your heart doesn't
you know feel so uh stressful or
stressed out uh and it's illegal because
it's you know it
it's a bit of an advantage
to
to other athletes so basically she said
she accidentally took these medications
it wasn't just one it was multiple
medications now this dennis oswald is on
this committee that basically said uh
she took these things that were in a
legal substance to
the olympics but we will still let her
perform or participate but if she
meddles or if she wins then she then she
won't meddle and i believe uh she got
fourth place so she wouldn't even do it
anyway but the reason that's so
important is because we've got people
like this past summer in japan um
who uh
uh you know for legitimate reasons smoke
marijuana but for whatever reason it's
like you can't
she was all you can't even go to the
olympics if you smoke right then you're
black but also it's like that's
important if you get black and you smoke
weed you can't go to the pit yeah but if
you're white and you take heart
medication which will actually give you
an advantage you can still compete you
just can't meddle so why couldn't the
person who was smoking weed while black
be able to participate in not metal that
that i think is the very significant
thing here and that's why dennis oswald
ended up on bone end of the week um for
that very reason because of the
decisions that they made it seemed it
seemed as if it seemed as if uh some of
those things may have played into that
decision which yeah it just seems a
little unfair that jakari you know
richardson would would would be like
because it's like also rightfully like
her
her
her mother i believe it was uh
passed away
and
it was
you know rightfully you're just like
coping right you're there and you find
out that a loved one has passed away and
come on is weed is free was weed really
a performance-enhancing drug right
exactly like if you're like oh don't
smoke weed because
uh
uh it gives you an advantage it's like
okay well we're talking about she is
literally one of the fastest runners
right now that was complete uh she was
definitely sought after just to to to
receive the gold
she was seen as talking about shikari
richardson right exactly
uh and so shikari richardson she was one
of the you know one of if not the
fastest runner uh sprinters that were
there and so if you look at someone and
you say
you can't smoke weed because it gives
you an advantage if anything it would
give other people an advantage because
it's tree it's it's you know going into
someone's lungs the lungs that are the
most important part when it comes to
sprinting
in a race right have you ever seen the
robin williams bit about this and i
think it's rob
live
um he he talks about the only way that
weeds is an advantage is that if there's
like a snickers bar at the end of the
the finish line right
like i said that's the only way that
marijuana is
right no completely i mean it's the same
thing it's the same thing when people
came after uh you know he didn't he
wasn't banned or anything because i
think it was obviously outside of the
olympics but it was when michael phelps
got caught smoking weed right there was
a photo i think of him
but you know he didn't lose any medals
right he didn't lose any medals
it sounds about white right right
exactly it sounds about white it's a
perfect way to say it and it's just like
one of those things was like another
sport that is like heavily
dependent on the lungs like hold your
breath it's like right you'd probably
take some pretty massive bong hits i'm
just saying but what i if he swims that
bad he's definitely huffing on the
bottom yeah and it's like again if you
think that this drug is illegal or it's
going to give you some advantage over
the competition i don't think so if
anything it's going to give other people
an advantage because you're the ones
that are putting things into your lungs
so i think at the end of the day it
really does come down to this this
double standard this dichotomy of why
did they oh she's one he's black and his
other girl is white oh this innocent 15
year old accidentally took
grandfather's heart medicine multiple
times right girl what are you doing why
are you taking heart medicine did she
confuse him with skittles she's confused
with skills how do you how do you you
know
were you were you did you chew the pills
did you just take it and then realize oh
you know what these don't taste like
skittles yeah were you popping a glass
of water with and that's how you swallow
your skittles none of this makes sense
the excuse is bs and that is why dennis
oswalt is on this list because he
decided to give this person the ability
to compete when shikari richardson
didn't get that ability right to even
compete not just like
just
right like oh you can compete but
because you found this drug in your body
but shikari was not
you can't compete right and this
15-year-old russian girl is said to be
oh you know what yeah you can make some
mistake yeah right you just can't meddle
right so go vote go to the at tony
michael's on twitter you can vote for
the bonehead of the week if you still
haven't um and you can select dennis
oddballs if you like and there's the
context behind that story um
maybe next time when we put someone so
obscure maybe maybe i should
describe what it is just give him a
title you know yeah well you know
someone says that sometimes so right you
know
tomorrow join us tomorrow at noon
eastern 11 central because in the second
hour we are going to go through the
bonehead of the week so i'm sure we're
going to talk a little bit more about
dennis oddwell's oswald tomorrow we'll
probably play the video and stuff as we
go through the bone of the week and
we'll award we'll award our winner of
the bonus of the week which appears to
be uh none other than eric trump you
guys seen we had eric trump on the
maybe we can get them again i don't know
yeah well go subscribe to the youtube
channel you can go watch that interview
and hopefully we can have eric trump
back on
the show at some point um in his
in his uh famous thing oh by the way did
you you you got a phone call from don
junior this morning and you you posted
that or was that last night that you got
uh i got the phone call yesterday okay
shared it last night okay so so you have
been getting a phone call from his
brother as well so everyone go check out
gabe's page that phone call that he got
from don jr until tomorrow noon eastern
11 central again we're going to do
bonehead of the week tomorrow we'll do
the [ __ ] list roundup until then surfs
up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking